ARUN KUMAR: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the penultimate
session for the day.
In this talk, we'll focus on
security by default in Anthos.
I don't have a demo,
so I can't really
blame the Wi-Fi if
something goes wrong,
but let's see how it goes.
[LAUGHTER]
So I am Arun Kumar.
I go by AK.
I'm a technical program
manager with Google Cloud,
specifically for GKE
container and Anthos security.
For an agenda for
this talk, we'll
start with what are the driving
philosophy and principles
behind Anthos security.
Then, we'll dig deeper on
some of the security features.
We'll then move on to
discussing some best practices
from a security
perspective for Anthos.
We'll finally talk about
shared responsibility
and how the responsibility
for securing
an account [? stands ?] between
the provider and the user.
Time permitting, finally,
we'll have a Q&A.
Let's jump right in.
What is the philosophy
that drives the security
work behind Anthos?
So we wanted security by default
to be the underlying theme.
Users should not have to become
security experts themselves
in their quest to
modernize their apps.
Our users have sophisticated,
pretty advanced,
and enterprise-grade
on-premise systems.
Most of these are for valid
business reasons, compliance
and regulations being
among the chief of them.
We want to meet
customers where they are.
The best of other
security capabilities
should be able to integrate
seamlessly with your existing
infrastructure.
Finally, at Google
and Google Cloud,
we take security very seriously.
We want our users to
benefit from our security
culture, which has
been battle-tested
and [INAUDIBLE] over the years.
We also have a strong
presence in the [INAUDIBLE]
and Kubernetes product
security committee.
We started by writing a
security white paper for Anthos
where we identified and talked
about major security challenges
that users face as they
migrate from traditional
to modern apps.
The first among them is about
enforcing consistent policies
across environments.
This could be across nodes,
across clusters, even
across multiple clouds.
Anthos helps you solve
this problem with ACM.
Moving on to the
second major challenge,
it's a question of how
can you effectively
secure your software
supply chain
in your organization and only
deploy trusted workloads?
The last one talks
about securing
multi-tenant environments
across a shared platform.
Two and three we'll address
shortly in our talk.
I also urge you to take a
look at our Anthos security
whitepaper.
It makes for an
interesting reading.
Moving on.
So our capabilities
are organized
across these five core security
design principles that we have.
The first of them is
infrastructure security,
then supply chain security,
and runtime security.
The fourth one is
configuration and policies.
The last one is compliance
and certifications.
We will only talk about the
first three in this talk.
We already discussed
configuration and policies
in the ACM talk in
detail in the morning.
Compliance and
certifications, that's
a whole big topic
unto themselves,
and they deserve more, they
require more than half an hour
by themselves.
Moving on.
Let's start with a
feature deep dive
and with infrastructure
and network security.
So Workload Identity,
which is in beta,
addresses the problem
of how you can
access GCP services from
within your Kubernetes and GKE
workloads.
Earlier, users faced
an impossible trade-off
between security and usability.
If you wanted to access
seamlessly GCP services
and resources, you either
had to forego principles
of least privilege,
or you had to deal
with burdensome config,
rotating credentials, and so on.
So with Workload
Identity, we built
a completely new IAM primitive
called identity namespaces.
So what it does is it takes
your Kubernetes service account
identity and binds it with a
Google Cloud Service account
identity.
And once that happens,
workloads only
have minimum and
required permissions,
and Google takes
care of managing
all the credentials and identity
stuff on the other side.
Moving on, node auto-upgrade.
This feature helps
keep your nodes up
to date with the most recent
and the stable version
of Kubernetes.
This is particularly
important in the context
of security patches, right?
So if there is a security
patch that has been released,
GKE automatically patches
all your nodes for you.
This is available for
both COS and Ubuntu.
You can also schedule
a maintenance interval
to define when you want
these upgrades to happen.
Shielded GKE nodes.
This protects the node
bootstrapping process
by anchoring with a vTPM.
A TPM is a specialized chip
that holds the encryption
keys in your machine.
A vTPM does the same thing
for a virtual machine.
When you use this feature, your
secrets and your credentials
are isolated and
protected in this vTPM.
Exfiltration becomes
super difficult,
and node identity is always
verified to the cluster.
So arbitrary nodes
can't steal credentials
and then enroll with them by
themselves to the cluster.
Application layer
secrets encryption.
We are launching this in
GA, I think, last week.
Please try it out.
With this feature, what you
do is you take your secrets
and credentials, you
encrypt them locally on ETCD
with a data encryption
key, or a DEK.
This DEK is then encrypted by
a key encryption key which you
manage and stored in Cloud KMS.
Cloud KMS, or Cloud
Key Management Service,
manages these keys for you and
also acts as a Root of Trust
upon which you can hold
all your credentials.
I have a mandatory
call-out to make here.
So by default, Kubernetes
secrets are plaintext.
They are not encrypted, right?
What GKE does for you is always
and automatically, by default,
encrypt all your secrets.
All of them are stored
encrypted in disks,
and GKE also monitors
access for them, and so on.
This feature is just an
additional level of control
that we provide you
for encryption, mostly
for regulatory requirements, and
if you have sensitive workloads
that you want to hold
credentials to revoke,
and rotate, and so on.
Honorable call-out, we also have
similar encryption mechanisms
where you can
encrypt [INAUDIBLE]
and disks, along with
keys that you manage
and you store in Cloud KMS.
Let's talk about a couple of
networking security features.
So network policy is a native
Kubernetes feature, right?
Most of you would
be [INAUDIBLE]..
What it does is it helps you
manage pod-to-pod traffic.
By default, any pod is visible
to all pods within the cluster,
and IPs are updated
in the cluster.
So this feature helps you
restrict pod-to-pod traffic.
Let's move on to VPC
service controls.
Do you want me to go
a little bit slower,
or is the pacing right?
OK, I'll take that as a yes.
Thank you.
So this is one of my
most favorite features.
VPC Service Controls
enables you to configure
security perimeters around your
GCP projects and resources.
So you control the
movement of data
both in and out
of your projects.
When the comm lines are
secured, data infiltration,
you're protected against
data exfiltration
from your projects.
All data and resource
accesses across boundaries
are also secured.
If your workloads span hybrid
environments, for example,
[INAUDIBLE],, you can use
private Google access,
along with VPC Service
Controls, to draw a perimeter
around your hybrid environment.
Moving on.
So this slide
actually represents
a timeline of the GKE
security team's efforts
towards hardening the GKE
product itself over the years.
So as you can see, it
started from July 2017,
and we have until 1.15.
Interestingly, as a couple
of tidbits, if you see--
sorry.
So if you see one and two,
these are actual vulnerabilities
with demonstrated exploits
that we secured in time.
So this represents a
GKE hardening timeline.
It's fair to expect that
efforts towards hardening
our on-prem installations will
follow a similar trajectory
and pattern.
The blue dots represent
feature launches
that we did over
the course of time
that we are also talking
about in this talk.
The green dots are
implementations
of default settings
that we've done
to reflect best
practices that we
have advocated in our hardening
guides, and blogs, and so on.
So these are available
to you by default.
I'll just pause a few seconds
if you want to absorb the slide,
and then I'll move forward.
OK.
How do you secure your
software supply chain?
This is from code, build, test,
package, deploy, and so on.
You start by using
managed base images.
Google builds and maintains
these base images,
and scans them for
vulnerabilities,
and automatically patches them.
So if you use this, this is
available on GCP Marketplace
to any GCP customer.
It kind of offloads
the responsibility
of using patched images
away from you to Google.
This is battle-tested,
used by Google.
We actually use
it for App Engine
on our own internal products.
Vulnerability scanning.
Container Analysis
is the official name.
This is a feature that
scans all your images
in your private Google Container
Registry for any known CVE,
Common Vulnerabilities
or Exposures,
from the public databases.
This works for Debian,
Ubuntu, an Alpine images.
Once you use a
feature, the data--
the report that you get
from container analysis,
you can either use
it internally--
if you have [INAUDIBLE]
by yourself,
you can [INAUDIBLE] the images
that your internal teams use.
But most importantly,
this lets you
prevent those unpatched
images from being deployed
using binary authorization.
This is a super
important feature.
What it does is it lets
you, as an organization,
define deployment
policies, and it
codifies the deployment policies
for an entire organization.
You can define
custom requirements
as signatures or
attestations, or you
can whitelist
repositories from which
you want images to be deployed.
So unauthorized images,
images that either
have a vulnerability, that
are too old to be valid,
that [? didn't ?] match
up with the attestation,
they are blocked
from being deployed
to any of the installations
at the Kubernetes--
at the GKE control plane using
admission controller for that.
At each stage of your
CI/CD pipeline in Google,
these attestations are
checked and re-annotated.
Let's move on to
runtime security.
So GKE Sandbox-- this is
a very important feature
if you run sensitive
workloads or if your workloads
have varying levels of
risk profiles, right?
Earlier, historically,
the way you isolate,
let's say, sensitive workloads
from, let's say, a staging,
or a developer, or a testing
workload in your organization
was either to stand up new
VMs or, in worst cases,
even to create new clusters to
isolate your workloads, right?
With GKE Sandbox, you
can achieve isolation
on the same node.
You can have multiple
pods at varying levels
of sensitivity and risk
running on the same pod--
sorry, running on the same node.
The isolation is at kernel
level and at runtime.
A plug in there--
my co-workers Tim
Allclair and Greg Castle,
they are giving a deeper talk
on isolation, container escapes,
and sandbox overall tomorrow.
So if you're interested,
please go ahead
and register for the talk.
Finally, a brief call-out for
Cloud Security Command Center.
This is the central place on
Google Cloud Platform where
you can unify, analyze,
and view all the security
data for your organization.
We are also integrated with
five of the security partners.
So if you use any of
these five partners
to augment your
security capabilities,
all of their tools are
completely integrated
with CSCC, and the data
is surfaced to CSCC.
So rounding up Anthos
security capabilities.
We went over
infrastructure security
in detail, supply
chain, and runtime.
We didn't get a lot of time
to focus on network security.
I highly urge you to look
at the documentation.
They're pretty detailed.
Honorable mention, Cloud
Armor [? protects ?]
from DOS attacks.
Istio Security-- we already
had Istio in the morning.
IAP, I'll talk about it briefly.
Master Authorized Networks
lets you accept only traffic
from whitelisted IPs.
I'll put it up for a few
seconds and then move on,
if you want to absorb it in.
Let's move on to best practices.
The first one is
centralized logging, right?
We recommend that you
follow the single pane
of glass architecture
wherever practical.
Of course, if you
have sensitive data,
if you have auditable data that
you want logged separately,
you're always going
to segregate it.
But having all your monitoring
and logging data centralized
is of immense value in the
case of security forensics,
or even as a way for you to
analyze and consume your data.
Anthos is well integrated
with Google Stackdriver
that you can use.
It has a single pane of glass.
Stackdriver also integrates well
with Prometheus and Fluentd,
if you're already using them.
The second best practice is
about protecting endpoints.
This, of course, deserves
a separate talk by itself.
But the tl;dr, I would say, is
we would recommend using Cloud
IAP, or Internet Aware
Proxy, that enables a more
context-aware evaluation
of a user's identity
or authentication.
We also recommend using
Apigee for API management
if you're operating
at that scale.
Three and four we
already discussed.
Three is about enforcing
network perimeter boundaries.
This is super
critical, especially
as your workloads
span multiple clouds,
or between clouds and hybrid.
Enforcing policies and
constraints consistently--
we primarily do it using ACM.
Of honorable mention is
Port Security Policies.
If you're a hardcore
Kubernetes user,
you must be well aware
of Port Security Policy.
It lets you define the
next level and very
low-level security
policies for authorization.
They also support
gatekeeper and OPA policies
via policy controller
via ACM that
lets you custom
create constraints
that you want to reflect
your business processes.
The last one is about
isolating workloads
in a multi-tenant environment.
So Anthos offers features at
multiple levels and layers
of isolation.
Firewalls, they might share.
So if you use GKE
private clusters,
it gives you private IPs.
Your cluster is hidden
from the internet.
Access to master is restricted.
GKE Namespace is a native
Kubernetes construct, again.
It lets you slice
and dice your cluster
to reflect your use cases.
You can create a new
space per app, per user,
per team, or per
sub-organization
in your company, and so on.
Network policies we briefly
touched upon before,
but essentially, the
suite of network policies
supported offer you
fine-grained layer 3 and layer 4
network-level access.
ASM, or Anthos Service
Mesh, on the other hand,
provides you service-level
access, or at an L7 layer.
Finally, we touched upon GKE
Sandbox, which offers you
protection at runtime.
So let's move on to the final
section, Shared Responsibility
Model.
So security in the cloud
is a shared responsibility
between the cloud
provider and the customer
or the user, right?
Broadly speaking, as we move up
the stack from infrastructure
as a service up to
PaaS and then to SaaS,
the responsibility owned
by the cloud provider
increases dramatically, right?
And things become easier
for you to manage,
and your responsibility
decreases
as you go up the stack.
So specifically speaking, if
you are using the infrastructure
as a service from
a cloud provider,
the provider is
responsible for securing
the hardware, the physical
machines, the storage attached
to it, as well as the network
through which you communicate,
right?
As you move up the path, you
get more things out of the box,
right?
The provider might most
likely give you an identity.
That's a full blown
identity system.
You'll get data and
access management tooling.
You'll have Authn
and Authz constraints
natively supported and a few
more features like that, right?
If you move further up
towards the SaaS layer,
that's a really cool
operating system there, right?
Most of the stuff, by
default, is managed for you.
So the provider manages
deployment, even application
security, scalability,
reliability, uptime,
load balancing-- the
whole suite of them.
So GKE or Kubernetes,
as you might assume,
falls in the PaaS layer.
So what Google owns and is
responsible for is a GKE
master, right?
The master is completely
managed for you.
So it is hardened, it is
secured, it is protected,
and it is upgraded
by GKE transparently
and completely invisibly to you.
You are responsible, A,
for maintaining the nodes
that you rent, the worker
nodes where you have
deployed your workloads, right?
But even here, if you
use managed base images
that we alluded to
a few slides back,
and if you opt-in for
auto-upgrade, even
this is completely
offloaded to Google.
Google takes care of
maintaining these nodes for you.
It's completely
out of your hands.
So what you're essentially
left with in GKE
is a responsibility for
securing your application--
your application, your
dependencies, and whatever
configuration you have.
And if you change any of the
default config and settings,
and then you're responsible
for securing the new surface
that these updated
configs open up.
So that's about GKE On
GCP shared responsibility.
When you move to on-prem--
and this is applicable for
certain other components
of Anthos, also--
as you can see, the shared
responsibility model
changes dramatically, right?
You as a user are responsible
for a lot of stuff.
So while this means that you
have a lot more to contend
with in terms of
management, this also
means that you have more
control and more visibility
over how you want to
define your workloads.
So depending on your compliance,
and your regulations,
and your existing
business infrastructure,
I think some of these
pieces will move and change,
but this is broadly true.